In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen."
The reading from the Sinoxarian for June 5th, on which we commemorate the Holy Hieromater
Dorothios, Bishop of Tyre.
On the 5th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Hieromater Dorothios, Bishop of
Tyre, in Phoenicia, at the time of Diocletian's persecution circa 304, Saint Dorothios had
acquired a vast and profound knowledge of the Holy Scriptures, and the tradition's in circulation
at that time about the lives of the prophets and apostles.
Forced to flee, he took refuge in Odysopolis, Varna, on the black sea, until the end of
Licinius' persecution in 320.
On his return to Tyre, he governed his church in peace for many years.
When Julian the Apostate began an insiduous persecution of the Christians in 361, the elderly
bishop aged 107, fled to Odysopolis again, but was arrested there by the tyrants' envoys,
and put to cruel torture with no respect for his age.
He died of his sufferings, and thus joined the choir of saints.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.